التي تشهد ايضا معارك طاحنه وساخنه تحاول
القوات الروسيه تطويق المدينه او توسيع
الطوق على المدينه في ذات الوقت الذي
يحاول الجيش الروسي فيه
اقتحام المدينه من عده جوانب مغطاه
بالضربات المدفعيه ورجمات الصواريخ كما ان
المقاتلات الروسيه تقصف باستمرار وبقنابل
ذكيه مواقع الجيش الاوكراني داخل المدينه
اذا توقف الغرب عن ارسال الاسلحه الاست
راتيجيكراني فذلك الامر بانتصارنا اما مع
استمرار الدعم المادي وبالسلاح الحديث
والمتطور فتقدمنا سيكون بطيئا نوعا ما
وتشهد بلده برلمايسكا الواقعه من الناحيه
الجنوبيه والغربيه ما بين مدينتيكا
ومارينكا معارك ضاريه حتى الان ذلك بعد ان
سيطر الجيش الروسي في معارك محتدمه منذ
اول العام الماضي وحتى الان على نصفي
القريه نشر بخصوص الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني
استطيع القول بان الجيش الاوكراني حاول
مرارا العوده وتنفيذها هجمات ضدنا وقد
تمكن من ايقافهم ونحن ما زلنا ننتظر
استمرار هجومهم لكنها دعايه غربيه بالعموم
لارهابنا هذا المكان هو سكن عسكريه للجنود
الروس في المناطق المتاخمه لمدينه افديفكا
المحتدمه بالمعارك نرى اثار الدمار الذي
خلفته قذيفه سقطت بجانب هذا الش هنا لم
يسفر هذا القصف عن ضحايا ولا اصابات لكن
من الواضح ان المنطقه تشهد معارك ضاريه
وقسم متبادل ما بين الطرفين الروسي
والاوكرانيا
وعلى هذا الحال تستمر المعارك في مدينه
افديفكا بين اقتحام روسي وصمود اوكراني
وهجوم مضاد دون منتصر حتى الان على الاقل
لقناتي العربيه والحدث رائد الاغبر اطراف
افديفيكا
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات